what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation happy Halloween don't get
too excited we just made sure to do this
for Halloween we're not doing Brooklyn
two times and every week we're just this
is just a special time and we were like
we got to probably gonna see some cats
coming in here behaving incessantly
because they're supposed to be fed in 10
minutes which means feed me now Mom what
are you doing I'm feeling the hunger and
you might think cats can't tell time
they can yeah and they're like Greg why
don't you just wait 10 minutes to film
we don't have those 10 minutes leave a
like uh trick or treat us with a like
yeah I'm in a bit of a calmer mood today
guys and I I don't like when that
communicates as is Greg depressed as he
must not be into this he must be sad
sad when your calm face reads just sad
letting you know I'm just not a this has
nothing to do with that I someone I wish
I want to try to lead with some common
today and I hope that's okay with
everyone I assumed personally
um but here we are let's see what this
Halloween episode is
it's time for round four of the
Halloween
[Music]
for the hollow
hymns what do you do you do I always
announce the heist yeah Amy what the
hell are you doing my right to announce
the heist as the defending Champion
defending Champion the only reason you
won is because no one knew you were even
playing it was a pathetic Act of pure
cowardice oh she's your girlfriend
Peralta not tonight she isn't although
don't kiss anyone else I love you so
much now
oh he's coming to play
they should team up to take down Amy
such a dork
I'm team Amy on that one Herald hasn't
won since the first year he's a has been
yeah well this has been has been with yo
mama all week sorry I feel like I
crossed a line I apologize
attention everyone
my ex-wife just died no more alimony
baby
oh yeah I'm happy for you man that's a
Halloween treat right there we'll be
playing for this a plaque that reads the
ultimate detective slash genius healing
Santiago should quit now I'm going to
stomp on your dreams it's fun to see you
so passionate I will slit you both open
from mouth to anus and wear you like
jackets oh wow
that's violent whoever possesses the
plaque at sunup wins now let's pick
teams I've got a ton of work you could
just leave me out this year interesting
what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm going to my desk heister dump if you
have nothing to hide then I'm sure you
won't mind me asking Hitchcock and
Scully to keep an eye on you whatever my
eyes will be glued to that ass yeah sexy
I choose Rosa so I select Charles Boyle
what oh just surprised because you have
such a strong connection with Gina but
I'm glad she's on my team I had
absolutely nothing planned for Charles I
totally planned everything for Charles
this is a nightmare ew what can Charles
Boyle do that I can't roller skate like
an angel [ __ ] I'm great on skates or I
can do anything Charles can except look
exactly like the body double I got for
him bill you can come out now
wow it's a virtual binder and it's
encrypted on this flash drive that's my
girl now where's the 3D model of the
precinct inside the keychain it's
a gram
wow
you're too close with Peralta I don't
trust you I only chose you to disrupt
his plans and now that you've served
your purpose you're no longer needed
that's cold only thing I'm planning is
getting my work done sure you are come
clean or we'll tell everybody about your
mistress I don't have a mistress you
don't but you're so good looking what's
the point
hahaha
it's go time now Gina whoopsie
bill but you gotta stand like me I'm
kind of like a young Brando so give it
that energy
it does look like volleyball too
There She Goes
nice
all right Bill The Time Is Now show your
face show your face to the world
what the hell pick your jaws up off the
floor ladies where did Gina Come From
Here Comes Jake what welcome
to the Big Show
ah trying to pick the lock El Capitan
that'll take at least three minutes by
which time I will have hidden this
plaque somewhere you will never find it
that's clever nice the Mortal Kombat
music I love it could break the window
but you would never knowingly destroy
government property would you
[ __ ]
oh no oh Gina Gina are you okay
let's go I'm fine
totally girl you look good [ __ ] is
part of the plan you'd like us to sold
your own in your absence and keep the
heist going yeah that's fine well you
heard the lady shooting since we
continue let's mop up this blood and get
back at it with all due respect sir I
don't think that's the best idea the
blood is dry we can just clean it up
after oh agreed
I say we reset the plaque and start over
what but my team had it Charles tell him
no Jake we're resetting what are you
saying the plaque
goes
back oh what a bunch of [ __ ] oh
yes
[Music]
well perhaps I can use a teammate after
all do you swear I can trust you yes
[Music]
I have a pizza here for Raymond Holt
what's going on I have a pizza here for
Raymond Holt which one of you bozos did
this us you know how much planning it
takes to get this many Pizza Guys here
at the same time a binder full of
planning whoa I'll guard the plaque
you're not leaving my sight bill can you
see what's going on no someone's taking
it yep someone's taking the place like
the dance everyone swiped the black
already yeah here he's leaving because
Terry's got work to do good job silly
voluntary yeah I'm getting messed around
like a pinball
who hired you who do you work for
everyone with a pizza get out of here
you could have pizza leave the pizzas
the caboodle the caboodle
someone was undercover Gina Gina was one
of the pizza men
was the operation a success
you tell me
got all my bull Cutters luck snapped on
the first try no one saw me leave gotta
hand it to you beautiful plan beautiful
execution oh my God I don't want tonight
to ever end
[Music]
dope Hiding Place not the smoking
Marianne is better than that she's a
work in progress
Ive knowing how
he wants to pay me in rules I have it
what how do you know do you usually
favors her left leg but after zero dark
Pizza she was suddenly favoring her
right yes yes
wow and I know exactly where it's hidden
in Santiago's secret cigarette stash how
did you find that whenever she gets
stressed out she smokes oh Santiago I
never mind
what is it
I feel you Amy
Bing pot and now it's time to send in
our cute little secret weapon Bing pot I
was talking about cheddar oh right
obviously over the past month I've had
him trained to retrieve plaques
[Music]
wow good boy cheddar I'm team Holt and
there's nothing you could say that will
change that okay fine then I guess I
have a new best friend and his name is
Bill
you're not serious are they related I
wonder they do look so similar oh
there's the black it's hitting the
evidence room the box Mark Cold Case is
1972. thanks bud we will always be best
friends
no they're halt with no hate cave the
last Sands are running through The
Hourglass
because your time is running out and you
are never going to get the plan Oh
Captain stop I I just can't let you
embarrass yourself oh no he threatened
to replace me and I freaked out hard I'm
sorry it's okay I knew you would betray
me that's why I fed you fake Intel what
the plaque was never in cold cases 1972
as if I just put it in a box unattended
uh but you did no I didn't then how do
you explain this uh I put the plaque in
my office Jedi
come here come here come here baby the
hell yeah thank you let's turn to my
office please oh no wait what is going
on we have the plaque yeah I just got
out of the vent to rub it in your faces
Terry did this rub it in your Face's
name your sex tape what
black lights what the hell oh my God her
Precinct is disgusting God no Hitchcock
and scully's death
look at the plaques our heists dumb
but you're setting a terrible example
for your daughters and they're going to
grow up to be total failures
your children are doomed
I don't know I've been working here the
whole time ask them well actually well
we both fell asleep and Jeffers never
woke us up coincidence
you're not going anywhere whoa
he's trying to get away everyone starts
panicking
I have the real plaque Gina
of course
three weeks ago Captain Holt asked me to
order a plaque that read the ultimate
detective's last genius I did it and I
ordered she really lost her teeth I
manipulated Captain Hull into choosing
boil as his partner all it took was six
bottles of dish soap see this is what
happens when Jake tries to wash dishes
by himself
whoa yes
he is helpless without boil
and the next phase of
faith that you knocked out your two
front teeth false teeth fake blood yeah
yeah swapped out a dummy plaque for the
real one
dentist you convince your dentist to
help you carry out the rest of the heist
no of course not go ahead I came back
wearing the perfect little Skies to make
sure I was never noticed by anyone
something so drab and uninspiring feels
like it's going to be a dig on me I wore
Amy's clothes there it is this is your
doing you and your male prostitute bill
is not oh dang
that suit is not drab it has a fun
salmon lining no Amy it made me
invisible and now that I had that how
did you know he was going to say heists
are dumb Terry says that about
everything everyone should wear
suspenders belts are done people should
swim forward the backstroke is dumb 30
grams of fat hummus is done
we're changing the name of the plaque
forever to what Gino and Maddie is the
ultimate human slash genius
I just want to say I freaking love you
losers happy Halloween happy Halloween
happy Halloween
[Applause]
I knew it ah this second this is lovely
it was injured I was like not Gina's in
on a camp B
B can't be
it's too obvious isn't it obvious Watson
isn't it obvious little little Playboy
you can Playboy
foreign
little cutie pie that was fun that was
very fun I had a fun time plenty of
alcohol required did you have fun I had
a blast it was like being in a Halloween
party except we were just watching TV
yeah and I forgot we were watching TV
and I was like we're at the Halloween
party doing a heist because heists are
fun I saw a blasty blast yeah no that
was creative I like the I liked how he
like locked them in there and then one
at first we gotta look up who that is
John Deere IMDb all right come on do the
IMDb yeah yeah yeah here we go here we
go here we go we're doing Brooklyn nine
nine gotta find out who bill was I know
I tried to catch him in the credits but
I couldn't it's too fast too fast
Too Furious so the thumbnail for the
next episode has been ruined yes I'm
happy and upset at the same time they
have directly ruined it thank you Amazon
for uh for yeah for the healthy spoilers
this one didn't feel like they tried to
be Halloween at all though
aside from the abundance of decoration
the tricking and the costumes kind of
there's like Halloween aspects but I'm
like it doesn't need to be Halloween for
that true it's like I'm I'm filling in
the Halloween stuff for it yeah yeah
nobody dressed up this year and uh
didn't have a Halloween aesthetic to it
yeah I mean previous of the Halloween
heists have had elements where it's like
oh yeah we're going outside for some of
it or at least there are people in the
precinct who are in costume or maybe you
know you had all the pizza men this time
but I thought back to that other one
where they did like the dance with all
the different like costumed
they're all in different costumes there
are like babies or something but yeah
yeah it's not the halloweeniest
Halloween Heist it's more of a heist
with you know Halloween decorations on
it can you multitask it's yeah his name
is Winston's story
and uh I don't think he's actually
related to happen so much like him yeah
I mean I'll Google is Winston's
storytella trulyo's brother but but no I
think he just I think they just cast
somebody who looks a lot like that is
wild because they look so similar yeah
yeah no it's a great match and I mean uh
you know Not a Bad Genie either uh but
perfect match for Charles yeah indeed
um no I thought this was a really fun
one I like seeing Amy and Rosa get along
I thought that some of the Dynamics of
mixing it up Rosa was really getting
into all of Amy's crazy planning
and yeah I didn't find this one to be
the cleverest of the heist
I thought it was fun it's not
necessarily the main unnecessarily
critical over an episode that's only
setting out to make you laugh and I
thought this was really funny and
entertaining absolutely but I'm just
trying to make it seem like we're
contributing something of relevance you
see I liked laughing there's a whole
Reddit Thread about people who thought
this guy was Joe the truglio's pants so
much like him yeah yeah yeah
um but no I I I feel like yeah the the
charm of this Heist is is in how it
builds upon the layers of the previous
heists as it acknowledges who won each
time and what they each have to lose and
then you sort of sing you think to
yourself okay so there's got to be a new
winner uh but I liked the the twisty
tourney uh mislead with Terry and and
the ultimate reveal with Gina I thought
it was you know a nice building upon the
the heist's structure it's turning into
who is jigsaw I know yeah yeah it really
is
um and so and and I mean too I wonder
for the fifth one I feel like the fifth
one is one where they will have to go
like go big in terms of the intricacy
and the Mystery but also go big in terms
of who's gonna surprise us and you know
I gotta give them I Gotta Give Them
credit because this was like while it
might not have been the the most clever
of the heists it was so fun and the
layers and the developments were a great
time because part of the point I guess
is to you know get Jake Holt and Amy all
in their very you know uh in their most
sort of smug confidence State and then
unseat them creatively and I thought
they succeeded in that yeah I want to
see the relationship go through some
really difficult times due to kind of
like a deep psychological breakdown of
watching Andy just any sambert just uh
gets so carried away like so obsessive
to the point where it causes emotional
Detachment and ruins his relationships
and friendships yeah I want to be like
the unhinged cop like you can't work
with him you can't date him you know
like when you see those cop movies and
then there's like sexual tension with
the with the male cop and the female cop
but you find out they used to date uh oh
that's why there's detention yeah yeah
that's what we didn't know but we nude
all along deep down yeah they have a
past relationship it didn't work out
because he was too into the job yeah he
couldn't unplug he couldn't switch off I
want to see that story unfold season
five once the Halloween Heist happens
it's going to take a real turn where
there's going to be a whole serialized
story it's gonna be a moment where Jake
uh when a case Gets In Too Deep it's
like a kid dies or something he goes
there shows up at her house drunk come
on in my husband's not home right now
just talk
they're having like intimate
conversation next to you know they start
kissing they make love yeah talk about
it ever again uh and her marriage
continues on
despite this infidelity and then he
lives with the guilt and it just eats
away at him and rots him over time and
he becomes it's not a real God doesn't
have any car moves they move on it's all
the case that's fair uh you know what
I'm thinking of the wrong genre that's
right way different solving the case
fixes your emotional terms
it was in a relationship all you need is
that once nothing ever becomes it wasn't
even about that really it doesn't count
to sex because it was about the case
yeah yeah
what you're really doing is is having
just making love to know about you and
not yes and you it's okay sometimes you
have to be no butted veering off of the
genre of course and and and that's a no
but in and of itself I should have yes
and did the cop genre as a whole exactly
you know exactly so um I'm gonna go back
I'm gonna sign up for an improv class
again just to you know make sure this
doesn't happen in the future and I'm
also going to watch all of the lethal
weapons finally it's gonna be great
Now's the Time I don't think it happens
in any of the Lethal Weapon movies
really they don't do the traditional
options
oh well fine I'll go watch Serpico again
oh no he's a gangster right or something
I haven't seen that since you gave me
the DVD as a kid wow you're like you
need to watch Carlito's Way it's like
all right I will and now there's a bar
around here named Carlito's Way that's
about to open so I would never go to
that bar terrible things happening yeah
I was like why would you want to remind
people like to hold that bar that's
awful yeah all right guys well this was
fun I had a good time plenty of alcohol
required it was a treat for Halloween
happy Halloween though everyone I'm not
doing the how Hitler's side
waving forward
that he made it really easy to uh yeah
he really ruined just forward arm
emotions yeah it's like our Nazi burst
in in World War II whoa
he's one of us
it's really yeah sure yeah it's easy
it's easy to make that mistake thousands
of frightening people
Nazis without reality
what oh yeah yeah no no yeah yeah sure
why not attentional hand gesture uh
whatever you guys need
foreign
anyway
there's a joke to yes and yeah yeah yeah
especially at a time when um you know
Jews are not dealing with any
anti-Semitism
make a Nazi joke it's not deathcon
anything right now Defcon Defcon anycon
in between uh all right that note happy
Halloween we'll see you all soon
[Music]